you
Oh
troops of the 1st Infantry Division
began operation Mastiff on 22 February
this Search and Destroy action took
place in tan Ninh Province 64 kilometers
northwest of Saigon on the perimeter of
a large rubber plantation these
infantryman located a Vietcong medical
training camp and field dispensary pure
water was produced by a camp distillery
and the enemy medical training center
stocked enough medical supplies to care
for a unit of battalion size there were
several buildings in the installation
one of them contained a gas operated
refrigerator others served as classrooms
and storage facilities no enemy
personnel were encountered in the
building's reams of printed material
were seized and rapidly screened by our
interpreters then the men began to find
secret tunnels and more mounds of
literature and gear were located one
tunnel was suspected of being occupied
by the enemy a concussion grenade was
used and five enemy personnel removed
one was killed by the explosion and the
other four rendered unconscious
among the injured were two Vietcong
women instructors medics of the big red
one administered first aid for shock
caused by the grenade blast this woman
found farthest back from the tunnel
entrance is revived in a short while
other tunnels in the camp area were
rechecked for additional chambers and to
locate any more Vietcong who might be
hiding there but none was found the
search revealed instead this Russian
made bolt-action carbine also found were
a number of Vietcong tactical maps which
were later turned over to Brigade
Intelligence the prisoners were removed
from the area for evacuation and later
interrogation captured supplies of value
were taken out and unwanted material was
destroyed on the spot then the buildings
in the camp were doused with gasoline
and the installation was set afire
on the outskirts of a village at Trung
law 48 kilometers north of Saigon
refugees are evacuated from the area by
troops of the 1st Infantry Division it
is 13 January and operation crimp is
about to begin the villagers are being
moved so they will not be endangered
during the sweep suddenly that night a
Vietcong mortar attack was mounted
against the camp at Trang wah as
artillery batteries fired back in the
darkness the medics tended the wounded
by lantern light at the aid station
the following morning damage to the camp
was assessed and it was found that
several trucks some 105 howitzers and
storage tents were lost one enemy mortar
shell was defective and failed to go off
damage in the area was extensive however
the wounded were flown out to a field
hospital in the rear three days later on
17 January Operation crimp got underway
armoured personnel carriers and tanks
wheeled into position for the start the
signal was given and units of a big red
one rolled out with infantry following
in the wake of the armored elements the
sweep through Viet Cong territory was
unremitting the enemy was driven from
the trunk off stronghold and the area
secured
two Vietcong guerillas one about 20
years old and the other 35 were captured
by men of the 101st Airborne Brigade in
the cui hua area 128 km/h / enclosing
was found among the young prisoners
possessions the older man had been
carrying a rifle when captured an ID
card belonging to the younger man was
dated 1917 making him 49 years old one
question he refused to say where he had
gotten the ID card
despite his Vietcong uniform he insisted
he was not a VC it was decided to fly
both prisoners back to headquarters for
interrogation by expert intelligence
teams since the elder captive also
denied that he was a Vietcong the flight
was made in silence as the two prisoners
realized escape was impossible then they
were at the field and the stockade
awaited them on 15 February in the area
around 2 Ivoire troops of the 101st
airborne found a Theatron monument to
the dead brigadier general Willard
Pearson brigade commander ordered the vc
memorial destroyed
after the explosion there was no trace
of the one-year-old memorial also in the
Tweed hua area the 101st airborne
soldiers carried out a two-day operation
on 18 and 19 February it was known as
Operation search out and was another
hunt and kill mission the men landed in
an open meadow soon afterward they were
moving through jungle country toward a
valley where the Vietcong were believed
to have a regimental headquarters the
objective had been bombed by Air Force
b-52s for several days prior to the
operation and no Vietcong were found
bomb craters were measured the damage
surveyed and an accurate field report
was compiled for Air Force officials
patrols combed the area for two days
without locating the enemy then 1dc
surrendered and reported the bombings
have resulted in a week-long evacuation
of Viet Cong dead on 20 february the
units of the 101st returned to the
pickup zone and reassembled for the
airlift back to the base the strange
mission was over the troops had walked
out of the area a distance of 24
kilometers without contact
they had come through a land devastated
by bombs as the men returned to their
camp for a three-day rest they carried
with them a first-hand report on the
effectiveness of air support in the war
against the Viet Cong
from the top of Hong Kong Mountain the
entire first Air Cavalry Base can be
seen on the night of 20 February this
mountaintop signal installation at on K
was taken under Vietcong mortar fire as
the enemy attempted to overrun the camp
due to a well-organized defense in place
the VC were beaten off the enemy had
penetrated barbed wire defenses on the
camp perimeter to gain access to the
mountain this man lost his new camera
but saved his life the attack knocked
out communications by destruction of
power units and some cables but no
signal equipment was damaged resupply by
air was begun immediately in an effort
to return the installation to
operational condition as soon as
possible during the attack the signal
men sustained some casualties by body
count
the Vietcong lost four men
elements of the first Air Cavalry
Division were filmed on 11 and 12
February as they move through enemy
territory in the bong-sun zone of action
the sweep was part of Operation Eagle
Claw here 288 kilometers north of Cam
Ranh Bay the troops advanced cautiously
in guerrilla infested binh dinh province
this hamlet seemed deserted but earlier
sniper fire had made the air mobile
soldiers suspicious of an ambush after a
careful search tunnels are located and
in them hidden Viet Cong the enemy
guerillas are taken along with their
weapons and other gear and moved out of
the area the village is destroyed by
fire a rest period is called before
starting out of the area with the
prisoners this was the second day of
combat patrol duty for these cavalry
Minh during the two days
the first CAV unit had penetrated deep
into the province and it was a long trek
out with the captives before nightfall
the patrol reached the assembly area and
checked in for air evacuation with one
enemy wounded and with all their
prisoners and captured material this
small part of Operation Eagle Claw was
completed successfully
at a staging area near Benoit about 32
kilometers northeast of Saigon men of
the 173rd Airborne Brigade load aboard a
PCs and convoy out toward the song dong
hai River filmed on 12 February these
units were part of a coordinated attack
upon zone D situated on the far side of
the river the forces crossing the river
were to commence a sweep in zone D
fanning out to the north from the
riverbank other elements of the 173rd
were moving into the zone from another
direction some delays were encountered
on the zone D shore but were overcome in
a short while the mission of this
two-pronged attack was to divert the
Vietcong while Special Forces came into
zone D and set up a new a camp within
timetable requirements of the operations
schedule these elements of the 173rd
began moving out during the five days of
the 173rd operations in zone D from 12
to 16 February Airborne artillery men
laid down preparation fire as required
by field commanders 105 millimeter
howitzers were used for the supporting
fire missions
at Benoit the main base of the 173rd
Airborne Brigade assault helicopter
crews were briefed on landing zone
conditions and target approach points in
zone D as they prepared to deliver the
second wave of troops shortly thereafter
the squadron was nearing the objective
area sixteen kilometers to the northeast
at touchdown the airborne soldiers
quickly deployed and secured the landing
zone perimeter defense included
81-millimeter mortar emplacements and
aiming posts were set up at once a sweep
of the area began and reconnaissance
patrols moved out through the wooded
hillside adjoining the landing zone
sometime later the undergrowth became so
dense the troops were halted
in the early morning hours of 12
February approximately 1000 troops under
special forces command prepared for an
airlift from Benoit some 32 kilometers
northeast of Saigon this airborne
movement is being made to zom cut an
objective area 16 kilometers farther to
the northeast at the objective the
troops are to set up a Special Forces a
camp
zom cot is situated at the confluence of
the song Bay and the song dong Lai
rivers it is in the middle of Viet Cong
controlled territory at the landing zone
the troops are flowed from the choppers
and take up defense positions patrols
are sent out to secure the prospective
camp site from this new camp Special
Forces will gather intelligence on enemy
concentrations and movements in the area
but first the camp must be established
logistic support for the project
commences with low-level drops of
immediate requirement items by cd2
Caribous for the most part these early
drops consisted of lightweight building
supplies air force strikes and 173rd
Airborne Brigade ground operations
provided cover for the a-team
then the Chinooks began arriving with
the heavier supplies and were directed
to load landing points votes to be used
for River patrol work were among some of
the first loads delivered on the second
day of the operation c-123 is of the air
force came in with color-coded parachute
drops but some of the cargo chutes
failed to perform and there was loss of
some items due to hard landing
as supplies rained down hasty defense
work continued with the drop schedule
completed the job of picking up the
material and creating a supply devil
begins salvage of drop damaged items
recovered some of the material and the
rest was discarded the work went forward
and the field supply depot was quickly
organized the two rivers which border
the camp one to the northeast and the
other on the west form a natural barrier
protecting the camp from surprise attack
by the Vietcong from those two sides the
patrol boats are launched and tested to
make sure they're operating properly
delivery of heavy equipment begins as
the Chinooks bring in bulldozers without
the tracks or blades because of the
weight problem these items were flown in
in subsequent deliveries beside the
earth moving equipment several trucks
were also delivered in sections assembly
of the bulldozers was begun at once and
the Vietnamese combat engineers
accomplished the task in very good time
by 14 February 3 days after landing camp
planning was well advanced work had
already begun on laying out the new
airstrip and the area was being prepared
for the bulldozers meanwhile the
bulldozers had been completely assembled
and were being used to level off
foundation sites for new buildings which
would be erected in the camp the troops
now well supplied had secured the area
and organized perimeter defenses work
would continue here but the a camp was
established